and at that point Johnny Cash no
honestly hey guys I got a I've got a new
gimmick I'm going to walk out and say
hello and then say my name next I'll say
Hello Johnny Cash and people like that
sounds stupid I'll put an I'm in there
it'll never work Johnny no it's going to
be it's going to the crowds are going to
go crazy hello I'm Johnny Cash it's not
quite working what if I wear a black
shirt
that's an adjust oh I didn't know about
all the Showmanship Johnny you [__]
loser okay so yes Johnny Cash at this
point uh has has established country
artist but Nashville's they're not
serving him well so he too kind of is
part June I need to
ejaculate come and help
me no it's
passed small
window